bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
et sur public sénat tout au long du mois
de septembre je vous propose de revoir
les moments forts de la séance lors de
la dernière session parlementaire
puisque tout au long du mois de
septembre bien les sénateurs sont
absents du sénat car ils sont en
campagne à l'occasion des prochaines
élections sénatoriales qui se tiendront
le 28 septembre prochain qui permettront
et de renouveler la moitié de la haute
assemblée là ce matin un texte très
important pour le sénat la réforme
territoriale
ce texte qui a suscité de nombreuses
oppositions de nombreux débats de
nombreuses inquiétudes ici au sénat ce
texte portait sur la création des
nouvelles super région 14 nouvelles
super région dans la version du
gouvernement
ce texte a été rejeté par le sénat au
début du mois de juillet puis il a été
adopté et amendé légèrement modifié par
l'assemblée nationale à la fin du mois
de juillet l'assemblée qui a elle
dessine et une france avec 13 super
région place cet après midi au début des
discussions dessinateur la discussion
générale ce moment où les orateurs des
différents groupes politiques se rendent
chacun leur tour à la tribune pour
donner leur avis sur un texte et vous
allez le voir on a tout de suite pu
constater qu'il allait manquer des voix
à gauche pour l'adoption de ce texte
c'était le 3 juillet au sénat j'appelle
bien sûr je me la parole dans la
discussion générale à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
bien monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président de la commission spéciale
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs je voudrais tout d'abord vous
dire le très grand plaisir que nous
avons engagées avec le sénat la
discussion générale sur le projet de loi
relatif à la carte régionale et à
l'organisation des scrutins régionaux et
départementaux
l'ouverture de cette discussion
s'inscrit dans un contexte où le sénat
pour aborder ce texte dans des
conditions optimales a pris un certain
nombre d'initiatives
d'abord il a souhaité que très
rapidement la commission des lois furent
réunies pour que le gouvernement puisse
devant l expliquer le contenu de son
texte des orientations et les objectifs
pour lesquels ce texte est présenté à la
représentation nationale
puis le sénat et c'était bien légitime
même si cela était nouveau par rapport à
la doctrine qui avait été la sienne
jusqu'à présent concernant les textes
engageant la réorganisation des
territoires a souhaité créer une
commission spéciale la présidence de
celle ci a été confiée au président y
est dont je veux saluer l'engagement et
le travail au sein de cette commission
comme président sa présidence continue
ses compétences de son intérêt pour ces
questions a permis de faire avancer la
réflexion du sénat et je veux le
remercier pour le travail qu'il a
engagées je veux également remercier le
rapporteur michel delbarre qui par ses
propositions sa sagesse ces orientations
a contribué à donner de l'épaisseur à ce
débat je ne doute pas que les échanges
que nous allons avoir au cours des
prochaines heures permettront
d'aller au fond des choses je veux
profiter du début de la discussion
générale pour redire à l'instar de ce
que vient de déclarer le premier
ministre pendant les questions
d'actualité la totale disponibilité du
gouvernement
pour entendre les sénateurs leur
proposition leurs amendements non pas
que je puisse m'engager
allait
favoriser l'adoption de chacun d'eux
mais en tous les cas je peux m'engager à
ce que chacun d'eux fasse l'objet d'un
débat et lorsque cela sera possible
d'une adoption c'est donc dans un état
d'esprit ouvert que le gouvernement à
bord de cette discussion ici au sénat où
l'article 39 de la constitution comme
cela est l'usagé conduit des sénateurs à
connaître d'abord d'un texte qui
concerne l'organisation territoriale et
larchitecture de nos collectivités
locales le deuxième point sur lequel je
voudrais insister en introduction
c'est sur les objectifs que poursuit la
réforme territoriale
dans laquelle le gouvernement s'est
engagé
ces objectifs sont au nombre de quatre
et je veux les rappeler parce que la
juxtaposition de ces objectifs leur
articulation donne à l'ambition du
gouvernement une cohérence qu'il faut
rappeler simplement pour que nous
puissions avoir des débats dans un
contexte de clarté et de transparence
le premier objectif qui est le nôtre est
de faire en sorte que nous ayons des
régions qu'ils puissent dans la
compétition européenne
jouer leur rôle
il ne s'agit pas simplement d'avoir des
régions compétitive il s'agit d'avoir
des régions fortes
qu'ils puissent par la mutualisation des
moyens de fonctionnement
dégager des marges pour investir la
situation économique du pays et plus
globalement de l'union européenne
témoigne de la nécessité d'engager des
investissements de croissance ces
investissements doivent concerner
essentiellement la transition
énergétique il y aura d'ailleurs un
texte qui sur ces matières sera discuté
au parlement mais aussi le développement
des transports de demain mais aussi la
nécessité de faire en sorte que
l'équipement numérique des territoires
et de tous les territoires et notamment
des territoires ruraux puisse être
assurée par un effort d'investissement
collectif nous devons aussi accompagner
nos filières d'excellence
nos filières industrielles d'excellence
qui par le biais les pôles de
compétitivité ont permis la montée en
gamme de ses filières et d'un certain
nombre de lots produits qui ont permis
aussi de développer des coopérations
entre les régions j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure et par conséquent organiser le
transfert de technologie la relation
entre le monde de l'université le monde
de la recherche et les grandes filières
industrielles et de services assurés que
l'innovation à sa place sur des
territoires pertinents cela est
l'objectif et l'ambition du gouvernement
est comme la question des économies est
souvent évoquée madame la ministre anne
marie escoffier elle a évoqué tout à
l'heure j'y reviendrai l'objectif de ces
réformes quelle que soit la strate de
collectivités concernées c'est d'essayer
de faire en sorte que l'on dépense mois
en fonctionnement pour investir plus de
manière à créer les conditions de la
compétitivité et de l'investissement sur
les infrastructures dont le pays a
besoin pour redresser son économie voilà
le premier objectif avoir des régions
fortes qu'ils soient des collectivités
locales d'investissement pour réussir le
développement économique de demain
deuxième objectif de la réforme
territoriale c'est de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait davantage de lisibilité dans
l'organisation territoriale française
personne ici n'est tac condamné en
raison de l'administration qu'il dirige
ou de la collectivité locale qu'il
administre nous sommes tous ici
suffisamment soucieux de l'intérêt
général suffisamment passionnés de
l'administration locale pour ne pas
reconnaître ensemble par delà les
sensibilités qui peuvent exister sur ces
banques que les collectivités locales
ont fait au cours des dernières années
oeuvre utile en oeuvre utile pour
développer des services publics oeuvre
utile pour développer des
investissements oeuvre utile pour
accompagner sur les territoires des
politiques culturelles et sportives qui
font le rayonnement de la france et ne
s'agit donc pas à travers ce débat comme
cela a pu être le cas parfois par le
passé de stigmatiser les élus en raison
de leur nombre
caricaturé en raison de leur inutilité
de les mettre là dans l'espace public
comme les auteurs de tous les maux ces
propos ont été tenus par le passé ils
ont créé beaucoup de divisions ils ne
correspondent pas du tout à l'état
d'esprit du gouvernement mais nous
voulons en revanche créer les conditions
d'une clarification des compétences nous
voulons là où il ya de lisibilité de la
complexité là où il ya des doublons
essayer de créer les conditions d'une
clarification de manière à ce que les
citoyens précisément soit plus près de
leurs collectivités locales que les
collectivités territoriales auxquelles
nous tenons puisse disposer des moyens
d'intervenir de façon plus efficace et
que nous puissions avoir à la fin une
puissance publique collectivités locales
comprises plus svelte plus véloce plus
efficace plus à même de répondre aux
enjeux du moment donc avoir des régions
plus fortes qu'ils soient des
collectivités locales d'investissement
clarifier les compétences ce sera
l'objet du texte qui sera présenté
devant la représentation nationale par
marylise lebranchu et andré vallini
relatives aux compétences entre les
collectivités
troisièmement
nous devons faire monter en gamme
l'administration déconcentrée de l'état
j'ai entendu hier notamment sur les
bancs de l'opposition notamment sur les
bancs de l'ump à travers le discours de
monsieur retailleau une préoccupation
que je trouve légitime et à laquelle il
faut répondre à l'occasion de ce débat
cette préoccupation
c'était la crainte de la relégation des
territoires et il existe effectivement
une crainte de la relégation des
territoires dans notre pays c'est la
crainte de la relégation des territoires
ruraux qui peuvent
et ne faut pas considérer ça comme
illégitimes s'interroger sur le fait de
savoir si des grandes régions
avec des conseils départementaux appelés
à disparaître ne risque pas de laisser
ses toits ces territoires ruraux
davantage encore dans le sud on sur le
chemin de